[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions in nashville tennessee this is
the ramsey show where we take calls
about your life your money your
relationships your mental health
whatever's going on in your life let us
know we're here to walk alongside you
triple
two five i'm 825-5225 deloney joined by
my good friend george campbell and we're
ready to talk about anything all of it
give us a shout triple eight eight two
five five two two five let's go to james
in indianapolis hey james what's going
on
thanks for taking my call i'm first time
and i'm just starting i'm on step two
just did my first budget but i'm
realizing i have 70 000 in debt
and i have a house that i don't use that
has 70 000 in equity
i'm a truck driver i live in my truck
every day
should i sell the house to pay my debt
first uh first just want to congratulate
you man how did you how did you find us
um
a friend recommended me to dave ramsey
class
very cool well welcome to our crazy gang
you're gonna change your life and we're
we're honored to walk alongside you as
you
man as you solve for freedom here so i
like that this is an interesting uh
scenario here so you live in your truck
and you're saying i have my primary
residence but i'm never there
never in the last year and a half i've
slept there twice and i didn't even want
to do it then i don't like the house oh
you don't even like the house
no okay is there a scenario where you
would need a place to crash
if you couldn't sleep in the truck
george don't say crash to a truck driver
sorry you're right
is there a place you'd want yeah you
need to sleep
okay i just found it um it took him a
second
i mean hotel if need be my parents have
an extra bed i'm not i'm not hard up for
i'm not worried about
i'm not worried about it i love sleeping
in the truck and my company will give me
another truck if there's a problem with
mine cool okay well i'm not mad about
this scenario it sounds like you want to
go all in you're willing to do whatever
it takes to climb out of the 70 000 in
debt what kind of debt is the 70 000
uh there's about twenty thousand irs
thirty four thousand student loans and i
owe my parents about uh ten thousand and
a couple other smaller bills okay i want
you to put the irs debt at the very top
of that debt snowball and attack that
one first
does that sound good
you cannot get rid of those guys you
don't want them after you
and then you're gonna list the debts
from smallest to largest beyond that
attack the next one and it sounds like
you can do this in one fell swoop if you
sell the house
correct okay james i'm in
if i'm you i'm doing this if i'm you i
i'm going all in on being a nomad and
i'd sell my house and i'd be debt free
now you have a thousand dollar emergency
fund right now
yes okay cool so have you done the math
on closing costs and all of that and
you're saying i will get about 70 grand
out of the whole deal if i sell
no the spot just occurred to me today
and i know i owe 35 on the house but
it's worth about 108.
okay cool okay i mean i would i'd be
working with a realtor right now if you
don't have one i would go to
ramseysolutions.com you can connect with
one of our elps endorsed local providers
in the indianapolis area who can walk
with you through this process and make
sure that you get the most bang for your
buck especially in this market but man i
love the the heart behind this james you
make one call for free
and you're dead free man that's amazing
and get that emergency fund fully funded
as soon as you're out of that debt and
you're going to be sleeping very soundly
in that truck from then on and not
crashing in the truck no crash just
sleeping sorry john i'm not thinking oh
my gosh
you just played
some bad mojo out there let's go to
aubrey in new york city what's going on
aubry
how's it going um excellent how's
everything good good good how are you
all right so uh i guess my question is
um i'm a new watcher of the show and
stuff like that i've discovered you guys
on youtube pretty recently welcome to
the gang man
our youtube guys love to hear it
yeah it's awesome um
so i guess the reason why i'm calling is
i the last couple i guess in may i
graduated college
i've been working since september and
full-time job and making thirty seven
thousand dollars a year
um
which in new york is is pretty much the
minimum wage here right um
yeah it's in it you know obviously
things here are very expensive and it's
it's tough to be here but recently my
grandmother passed away um and she
essentially left me two hundred thousand
dollars
and
i mean i don't know the first thing
about what to do um
as far as moving forward i'm 25 years
old
i was living at home with i guess with
her up until the you know up until now
just trying to help out any way i can
um and now that i'm you know getting
this money i don't really know
whether i should you know what i should
do i mean you know obviously living
buying real estate here is really
expensive yeah um and i'm making so
little that even to keep up with
payments for like any type of mortgage
or
maintenance and stuff like that will be
relatively difficult um aubry what do
you do for a living man
i'm i'm basically i work in ed sales i'm
an account executive
in what sales
uh in advertising advertising okay all
right um
other than texans who are incredibly
obnoxious
um and i'm one of them so i'm just
saying is my friends from new york
are really intense on this is i don't
care it's a million dollars a square
foot don't care this is where i live
what is it about new york
that is worth
scraping by like you're doing
financially
and here's what i'm asking you've got a
200 000 gift and by the way i'm
heartbroken over your grandmother's
passing i'm so sorry to hear that
but she left you a gift
what is it about new york that keeps you
there could you go get a job as an ad
exec in a city that is infinitely less
expensive and really set yourself up
financially
with community friends that you could
start somewhere else
i i actually work remotely so i don't
even
go anywhere
yeah i i can live anywhere in the
country are you open to going somewhere
else
i i am but honestly um i really i've
never even gone on a vacation from here
i've i've been in new york my whole life
and um
i don't really know much else i mean
i've the only place i've visited in new
york in the last 10 years out of state
is florida
so i'm kind of
i am not opposed to leaving just because
of i mean look you know living here
i mean
the money doesn't really count too much
here like it's it just feels like
even if i use the money to buy a place
here the the maintenance of living here
is
as expected i'll still be living
relatively paycheck to paycheck my
ability to save will be still
negligible right
well man i
i know that's scary if i'm if i'm you
i would take a little bit of that money
and go go somewhere go look around a
little bit but i think this is one of
those watershed moments you're 25 you've
been care taken for somebody that you
loved and they passed away they left you
this incredible gift and you're being
very wise about saying what's the best
way i can steward this gift is it to
rent a one-bedroom apartment for 18
months in new york or is it to buy a
five-bedroom home in kansas or is it
right so you can live wherever you want
and sometimes it sounds ridiculous if
you're in the opposite situation but
sometimes endless options is paralyzing
too right and so here's what i want you
to do man i want you to get with a
trusted friend i want you to get with a
mentor who's a little bit ahead of you
on the journey
and sit down and say
i've got an opportunity to get out of
here and go build a life where it's not
so expensive where i can build friends
and community
will you walk alongside me and make sure
i don't do anything dumb with this money
and right now i just park that money and
you can drop in an index fund you can
put it in a high yield savings account
for a little bit until you have a next
plan
but man i want you to start thinking
about getting out of there and using
this money as it's to maximize it as far
as it will go we'll be right back
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchhillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five i'm john delony joined here by
george campbell and we are taking your
calls on relationships and money and
life give us a shout triple eight eight
two five
five two two five let's go to nathan in
florida hey nathan what's up
oh hey guys how's it going outstanding
brother how are you
oh i'm doing all right very cool what's
up uh
well
[Applause]
i'm
coming up on the weekend and i'm
thinking real hard about uh
i'm i'm on baby step two
and
doing pretty good on my budget i had a
few curveballs last month
um
i'm just crunching numbers and it's just
i'm not making the kind of headway that
i'd like to make i've got
a little bit of a predicament here i
fixed a vehicle
that was previously broke down and sit
in my yard forever
so now i have two vehicles at work
one that has
260 000 miles on and one that's got
sixty thousand miles
and the one that has sixty thousand
miles on it is half my debt i'm forty
thousand dollars in debt and that car is
twenty thousand dollars what kind of car
is it so
it's a
ford focus
sell it yesterday
what's it worth sell it if you sold it
today 10 right
well
i'm not sure i i was going to take a
drive down to uh
local dealer and see what they would
give me for it i hadn't really poked
around too much on what i could sell it
for but like i said i owe 20 on it
and i have two working vehicles
the only hang up is
okay go ahead i was just wondering if is
you're saying it'll be definitely worth
less than 20 if you saw
i thought you had twenty thousand
dollars in debt total he's got 40 total
20 is on the car okay all right so i'm
wondering could you sell this thing for
20 or more
well i'm that i'm not sure of i just i
know the way that the uh the car market
is right now that everything's just
inflated on cars and that's one of the
reasons why i'm kind of considering it
and
especially since i have a working
vehicle
on the side already but the only hang up
i have is
it's a great time to settle a vehicle
it's not a great time to buy
you don't need another vehicle right now
you've got one right you've got that
beater right
yeah but that's what i'm saying is it is
a beater of beaters it's got 260 000
miles what kind of car is this
it's a ford f250 with four wheel drive
all right the the goal here is not
the goal
i want you limping along here
right okay and if you tell me that this
thing can safe and can get you from a to
b you're not going to get any dates out
of this thing and you're going to have
to duck your head when you enter into a
you know in a grocery store parking lot
that's that's part of the deal man but
could you drive it 10 000 more miles
without it exploding
um well i'm pretty confident on without
it exploding i mean it's got dry rot set
and on the tires but
get some tires don't don't drive on
rotten tires
right
but i don't want you to overthink this i
want this to make i want you to be
uncomfortable you are running for your
life here brother
right right now you're not driving a
death trap but you're running for your
life right right right it well i mean i
guess what i'm getting at is you know it
uh it's not the greatest on gas i'm like
this little four-cylinder car and what
i'm thinking is
another possibility is sell both the
vehicles and whatever money i can get
out of the truck
uh go get me a little gas efficient car
or do you think i should just maybe i'm
overthinking it and just waiting with it
dude just rock that truck until it the
wheels fall off and do it safely of
course but you're not scared to fix a
car so that's good news but that clears
half your debt i'm not worried about
fuel efficiency i'm worried about debt
payoff efficiency
what's your payment every month on this
on this
on the little car
uh 321 dollars
so you would free that up and you would
have that every month back in your life
to attack the other debt what's the
other debt the other 20k
uh the other 20k is a mixture of
personal loans and credit cards
so we're going to list those
smallest largest at that point we're
going to attack them with a vengeance
and every payment you free up is going
to move this process along faster and
faster what's your income
my income is
sitting at just under fifty thousand
dollars a year all right i'm sorry
that's the take home take home 50k great
this is great news you're bringing over
4k a month and we're going to tighten up
that budget as far as we can take it to
free up as much of the money to attack
the rest of those debts and every time
you get in that truck i want you to say
i hate you i'll never borrow money again
i hate you give it a name yes give it a
name and j oh my god put all that angst
and energy i'm gonna get rid of you i'm
gonna save up some emergency fund i'm
gonna get me another car sean hates your
truck more than you do i'm hating it for
you and by the way when you do your
research don't just go to a local
dealership i want you to check vroom
carvana all of those sites check what it
would get on private and facebook
marketplace do your due diligence to get
the most you can for this car and that
you are in a beautiful spot because you
got two cars and so
list it on a private sale and see what
you can get for give it a week give it a
couple of days to see what what what
could happen right i've heard crazy
stories about carvanha just paying way
over what they don't even get in the
market so that's what i'm just saying
just check them all out it'll take you
five minutes to go on those sites and
plug in some numbers and they'll go hey
we'll give you 22 grand today
and we'll come pick it up but a gas
conscience and conscientious car with 60
000 miles that will do well sure it'll
do well good for you brother all right
let's go to tyler in
uh where's tyler at birmingham alabama
what's up tyler
hey guys how are you doing today good
how are you brother
i'm doing well so i am a
23 year old second year medical student
uh my wife works full-time
she's been working full-time since we
got married at 19. and i worked as an
emt full-time plus throughout undergrad
our goal has always been to get through
medical school debt-free
and
during undergrad we were able to save
about 60 000
which we have since spent um on my first
fourth semester of medical school
additionally uh my parents set me up a
student account for undergrad
that thankfully i didn't have to use
because i got a full ride scholarship to
undergrad wow and
it has grown to about 45 000 which would
cover my next three semesters we haven't
had to dip into it yet
um we're down we've spent most of that
savings we're down to about six thousand
dollars which is essentially a
three-month emergency fund for us
um
and basically so we're lined up to pay
for my next three semesters and we're
trying to figure out how we're going to
pay for the last semester medical school
cool and you have three semesters to
figure it out right right
and we're trying to save as much as we
can
with our monthly cash flow we're able to
save
and not a ton maybe one or two hundred
dollars a month
um
to give you an idea about some of the
other things financially for us
our primary residence we own
the mortgage has a balance of around 100
000 and it's worth around 190.
we paid some on that throughout and have
renovated it to be able to get that
equity up
and we also have around 30 000 in our
roth iras between the two of us
and that's kind of a total view for us
and we're trying to figure out if
there's anything we can do that we're
not doing already yes we'll try to pay
for that last semester medical school
your new goal is to cash flow and invest
in yourself which means this is hard to
hear we're not going to do any investing
right now
we're going to pause that if you're
getting a refund we're going to change
your withholdings because that's going
to give you a raise in your budget every
month we are going to be dead set on
cash flowing
this med school and then that's it
that's all we're focusing on right now
and when you graduate you guys are so
young and you're already doing great but
right now you got to focus on cash
flowing this thing and you only have 100
bucks of margin to do it which is going
to be really tough
and i'm going to tell you something
crazy and george you can tell me this is
a terrible idea
um
i would at
you say you're 23 right
23 23. the chances of you getting
through med school and then getting
placed somewhere else are quite high
right
um it's under the pen i'm going to
attempt to mark to match at my home
university but there is a chance right
so
i would strongly consider sitting down
with my wife and saying is this a moment
where we sell this house it actually
earned us 90 000 in equity we're gonna
get through school debt-free we're gonna
get matched and we're gonna get a cool
apartment whatever city we get matched
in and to finish up our residency and
then you're gonna be done with med
school you're gonna owe nobody anything
and then you can get the house of your
dreams because all of your money will be
yours that's not a terrible idea john
you're right really i like it usually my
ideas are terrible thanks george we'll
be right back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
health care coverage that would meet our
needs chm is not health insurance but it
is christians helping other christians
by sharing each other's medical bills
the medical bill sharing from chm was
exactly the way the website described it
there were no surprises no bait and
switch no hidden agenda
chm did everything they said they would
by sharing all of our eligible needs
we like that it's a non-profit ministry
and that we were being better stewards
of our money all while helping other
families
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business
get started today and check us out at
chministries.org
backslash budget
that's chministries.org
backslash budget we absolutely believe
in it
[Music]
this is the ramsey show eight eight two
five five two two five and it is
resolution season and if you're like
most people you make resolutions on new
year's day and you give up on them by
valentine's day have you already quit
yours george that's a personal attack
john not gonna answer that
yes you're not near as bulked up as you
said you're gonna be but that's cool why
do you
why do you fail george because you're
trying to figure it out on your own
so if you've decided to take control of
your money this year don't do it by
yourself get the support and
accountability you need by joining a
financial peace university class you'll
go through our proven money plan with
other people who will help you stay
motivated because they're trying to get
out of debt and build wealth just like
you
right now there are hundreds of fpu
classes getting started both in person
and online on the internets so forget
the lame resolutions
george make 2022 the year you take
control of your money and don't do it
alone find an fpu class and get started
for free at ramseysolutions.com
fpu that's ramseysolutions.com
fpu
let's go to jackie in honolulu hey
jackie what's going on
hi um how are y'all doing remarkable how
are you
great um so my scenario is my husband
and i are on baby steps four and six no
kids
um congratulations he gets out of the 90
thank you
he gets out of the navy the end of this
month i work as a real estate agent
uh so the pay is not um often or it's
only when i close
and so far that's been about every other
month since um last
uh september
and so we're gonna we're planning that
we're gonna be living out of our
emergency fund
but we're kind of
wondering should we get part-time jobs
supplement this time my husband's in a
program right now to learn java software
development and it won't be done until
the end of may
so that's about when he could actually
conceivably start getting a full-time
job again so i'm gonna let george hop in
on this i want a quick question across
the united states the real estate agents
that i know
have had better the last 24 months
better than they've ever had in their
life sometimes two and three times as
much
has it been different in hawaii has it
really been shut down
it's not been different in hawaii but i
just started the previous august and
it's a hard market here to get into
there you go okay all right so you're
you're just getting your feet underneath
you
yeah very cool okay
yeah i mean if you're willing to do a
part-time job or two or three right now
that's what i'm doing until i can pick
up some of this real estate stuff and
your husband gets through the program is
this program full time he's not able to
pick up a side job as well
um it's not full-time he's planning on
doing lyft seeing how that works out
doing
i think it's lyft or uber he's he can
only do one of them until he gets the
hawaii uh driver's license uh so he's
gonna be trying to do one of those in
the morning
and then possibly in the evening some
nights very cool sure and he can also
look into a lot of the delivery apps
like instacart and shipped and sometimes
people can make even more money on those
and there's no one in your vehicle ever
which is kind of nice
so he can also look into a lot of those
different apps and you can make 20 30
bucks an hour i use instacart and
shipped all the time and big fans of it
and you can make some great money just
in tips
i think
yes uh i actually mentioned to him
getting a part-time job and he's iffy on
me getting a part-time job because that
takes away from my ability to
generate clients so that we can actually
make some more money it's a push-pull
just nervous yeah i think it's good to
be nervous but i'm not a huge fan of
y'all
in like making a plan to live out of
your emergency fund because then it's
not an emergency fund anymore if you
expect it it's not unexpected right and
so i would much rather see y'all
scratching claw and you're right maybe
you're out delivering things and you're
handing cards to every person you see
and you can use it i don't know that
would be cool allowed to do that but
what's ways you can double dip um and
figure it out but i do get there's
attention when you're trying to build a
new business you want to go all in
and not split your attention but you
also got to eat but it's one of the most
flexible things as well you can just
turn the app off if you've got a sudden
real estate appointment you know you
kind of know your schedule it's a little
more flexible with real estate so i
would try to plan around it to go you
know i'm not in an office 40 hours a
week
so i can plan to go hey i'm gonna devote
four hours to delivering some some food
right now from the grocery stores and
make an extra hundred bucks and if you
get a call on the way you can talk to
the yeah you can get it yeah all right
let's go to danielle in reading
pennsylvania hey danielle what's up
hi there how are you
well i'm a little stressed at the moment
so i'm calling to get some advice all
right
my adult daughter and her two children
are living in my house
and she has always had a
tendency to do things um
impulsively and there's been
a shortage of maturity i will also add
to
some issues that we've had and
recently she has now started a new
relationship
and i've i've seen some things that i
don't like in her
and i feel like i want her to move out
of my house but i don't want it to be
you got to get out i
i need
maybe some guidance on how
to work this out because i want her to
get out of my house
honestly tell you thank you for your
spirit and thank you for loving your
baby girl and also this is hard but
thank you for
having boundaries
and all of those feel like they're in
tension with one another another and
they are but they're not all mutually
exclusive so you're heading into some
choppy waters but the right water isn't
so good for you so why did she come move
into your house
um she
this is one of the impulse things
she
went and kind of eloped let's say with
someone she had been seeing for a short
time
um i'm going to say about two years or
two and a half years into it he up and
left
and left her with
her daughter and their one-year-old at
the time and she wasn't generating
enough income and i would never let my
loved ones just live in the streets so
certainly come home sure and i i didn't
feel like you know you have three months
you have six months and she hasn't been
making money but i i will take
i will take the responsibility and say i
think that i have let it drag on too
long
because i've seen her
not
become more responsible and be
taking steps to move out she's quite
comfortable and and now i feel like
you're
not just comfortable but you're taking
things for granted and
you're enabling them
there you go so here's what i want you
to do
i want you to
write her a letter
and i want you to go by yourself and it
may take a couple hours it may take a
couple of days it may take five drafts
one draft i don't i don't care but just
get it right
and i want you to have a couple of parts
in this letter the first one is i want
you to tell her
how important she is to you
how much you love her the things that
you see in her life that you are proud
of her about i want you to let her know
that and it's important that you write
this down and i'll tell you why but then
i want you to talk about
here's how i've loved you stepped in the
gap and here's the next way i'm going
gonna love you which is i'm gonna walk
alongside you as you leave the nest
and i want you to take her out somewhere
we joke here at the office i'm always
telling people to go to breakfast our
friend anthony like to have these
conversations at dinner
i think better in the morning so i like
breakfast but i want you to take her
somewhere and i want you and it may not
even be in a restaurant it may be in a
private place but i want you to read her
this letter and then hand it to her and
here's why
when people are in this situation as
soon as they start to get a hint that
i'm going to be homeless
or
less less specific i'm getting abandoned
again i'm getting left again
their brain shifts their critical
thinking literally goes offline and
their fight or flight takes over and so
they start hearing things
as that are not always real when you
write it down and hand it to him she can
re-read it and reread it and re-read it
and then eventually get to the okay my
mom even if i don't agree with it
in my mom's heart she loves me and she's
trying to walk alongside me i want you
to stay on the line i'm going to give
you a copy of total money makeover by
dave and i want you to give that to her
as a gift i want you to help her make a
budget i want you to give her a ramp say
in three months i'm gonna i'm gonna go
with you to look at apartments i'm gonna
go with you to look at little at rental
home whatever that looks like i'm gonna
help you with your job i'm gonna walk
alongside you
but at this deadline
is when we're moving out
man she's lucky to have you thanks for
loving her thanks for caring about her
and thanks for doing this the right way
we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the ramsey show let's go
out to linda in new york city hey linda
what's going on
hi thank you so much for taking my call
today of course how's it going
i have a question so my husband and i
have been doing our best to
you know be financially free um
be at peace with our finances we're at a
step where we're looking to purchase a
property uh
in new york city in the neighborhood we
live in most of the properties are
around a million if not more
so just getting into
debt for 800 000 on a mortgage really
scares us so if you have any advice on
how to proceed
well it should scare you because that is
a lot of money eight hundred thousand
dollars it's the biggest financial
decision you will ever make in your life
so you have a healthy level of fear but
let's talk through the numbers and see
where you guys are at so you're out of
debt and you have a fully funded
emergency fund
yes we have around uh 53 000 in an
emergency fund okay is that more than
you need in the emergency fund or is
that appropriate for three to six months
of expenses uh
i think that would be a year where we
try to be as conservative as possible
okay
well how much do you have for a down
payment
so far we have around 130
where by the end of the year we can add
in another 100 so
around
uh 230 240. okay what's your household
income
uh around 300. okay that's some good
news there what do y'all do for a living
uh my husband is in finance and i've
recently started also in finance
very cool so is your take-home pay
around let's say 200 000
uh
yeah that would be fair okay so that
means you're taking home around 16 17 a
month and so with our parameters what we
want you to do is to put down 10 to 20
at least 20 would help you avoid pmi
which is that private mortgage insurance
which on that massive loan would be
hundreds and hundreds of dollars a month
that you throw away to the lender to
protect them and not you
so let's say you could put 20 down
and then let's say you did a 15-year
fixed rate mortgage which is the only
mortgage we would ever recommend
and then let's say you wanted to do with
our parameters and have that be less
than 25 of your take-home pay
right
so based on my math you're looking at
let's say
4 200 bucks for your mortgage payment
and so what i like to do is not look at
can we afford an 800 000 mortgage i want
you to say if we can afford 4 200
a month on a 15-year fixed-rate mortgage
with this much down how much house does
that let us afford and right now you
might be able to buy a six hundred
thousand dollar house let's say which
means we gotta be more patient we gotta
save up another hundred thousand it
might be another year so what i like to
do is use the ramsey solutions uh
mortgage calculator you can find that on
our website ramseysolutions.com click on
free tools
and start to play around with that and
don't let it
make you
live in fear but let it give you freedom
to start dreaming about what that next
step is and if that next step is hey i
think we're going to be ready a year
from now that's great or if the step is
all right we can afford a tiny condo is
that something that we're going to be
happy with are we going to sit here with
regret and still have 700 000 in debt
then i'm going to pause and go all right
yes renting is the worst and yes it
feels like we're throwing money away but
what if you saw it as buying yourself
patience and you saw it as we're gonna
get one step closer to our vision by
renting for another year that's a very
different picture to paint do you feel
that
um it is kind of scary because most of
the houses in the neighborhood are not
even
beautiful i mean most of them
are very they would need renovation as
well even at a million oh yeah are you
locked into this neighborhood
um if i in terms of our work we are
because we want to be close to the city
uh if we go more deep in you know
farther away from the city uh we might
get something for around 800 but
or maybe 700 but we're still at like for
200k
you know or missing out on the
neighborhood that we want to be in sure
and you're definitely wanting to stay in
new york city proper
uh given our work situation our career
aspirations yes okay so there's a hard
it depends on how you look at it but
i hear this a lot i know george i know
you do too
there is a hard reality
when you look at your income whether
it's 300 000 or it's 30 000.
and i really had my heart set on this
neighborhood it would be this level of
convenience for us it would provide this
many opportunities i found the same
problem here in nashville when i moved
here it was three sometimes four times
more expensive than where i moved from
and i wanted to be in this community and
and ultimately it couldn't happen
i either was going to have to concede on
15 more minutes or 20 more minutes or 30
more minutes in a commute or i was gonna
have to do what you're doing which is
really fret
over spending more money than i'm
comfortable spending way over leveraging
myself for a house i don't even like
it's not even it it has no i don't like
it i don't like living in it
and so anytime
whether you're a single or
a single whether you're single or in a
marriage relationship george
when you box yourself in to a decision
that's when you end up making a decision
that's not a wise when you say it's
either this or it's either that you end
up going okay we have to and you don't
right well then the next call becomes
hey we have eight hundred thousand
dollars in mortgage debt and we are
scared out of our minds or we both work
in finance one of the most volatile
industries and i just read some news
today that um some of the big financial
players gonna be are scheduling some
layoffs this year right it's a messy
time yeah one thing i always tell folks
is trust your gut and if you're about to
take on a mortgage that feels gnarly
true
trust your gut listen and i'll also say
this
i grew up with not a lot my wife grew up
with not a lot we didn't have a lot and
dave has been helpful coach right it's
pretty cool that i get to have him as a
personal coach on some of this stuff but
there is a scale to this right and so if
you are making 300 000 and you've never
made that kind of money before
a 500 000 loan feels incredible
and you got to rest assured that if your
job is secure and your
income is safe and you're not making
dumb purchases that you are going to be
okay yeah right and it's just you got to
balance the it's it's a ratios question
so let's look at the reality for a
second linda i did some math for you on
our mortgage calculator if you put down
230 grand on a million dollar home you
are looking at a sixty four hundred
dollar a month payment not including
escrow and not including all the closing
costs and all the things that come along
with home ownership the joys especially
in a in a crappy million dollar place
you have to fix everything constantly
because it's new york city and so you've
got community taxes you're looking at
you're looking at 40 of your take-home
pay being eaten up by this mortgage
while you're trying to do the other baby
steps while you're trying to live your
life be a homeowner fix all the things
and so here's what this new picture
looks like you would have to put down
550 grand to have that mortgage payment
be reasonable and give you financial
peace and you go 550 grand
let me remind you you make 300 000 and
you just told me you can save at least
100 grand a year so what this now looks
like is man three years from now we're
going to have a home that we love we're
not going to be rushed into it it's
going to give us financial peace we can
afford the payment easily
i'm breathing easier just thinking about
it
so that's the picture and you live in
new york city which means you got to buy
yourself a lot more patience than if you
live in a small town in iowa right and
george you're a good picture of this for
folks because you worked at a fancy
place you got a big fancy job
yet you and your wife said we're gonna
start with a condo we're gonna pay this
thing off
and when we get there and we can breathe
then we're gonna say okay what what is
the fantasy what's the myth what's the
thing right what's the dream yeah um
walk people through your psychology
there because that's hard it's hard well
the problem is if you go to the bank and
say hey we'd love to buy a house how
much money will you give me they will
give you an astronomical number and you
go oh my gosh we're rich the bank is
willing to loan us eight hundred
thousand dollars they're our friends
they're our friends look how nice they
are no i want you to look at your budget
your bank account but how did your
decision how did you
reign it in in inside
it's amazing when you pre-decide we
pre-decided hey we're going to put down
as much as possible and we're going to
pay it as quickly as possible and we
want to do it in less than four years
because anything more than that feels
like too long of a journey for us to pay
this thing off with a little bit of
intensity so that's what we did so we
let that dictate the house that we
bought it's kind of like deciding before
you go out to your friend's house like i
will only have one drink or i will not
look at the dessert table or you got a
pre-plan if i wait till i look at the
dessert table all she wrote you know
what i mean nailed it hey appreciate you
george campbell thanks for the guys in
the booth kelly ben
james even zach
hey hope you're having a great day be
kind to one another we'll see you soon
on the ramsay show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions in nashville tennessee this is
the ramsey show where we talk about your
money and your life and your mental
health your relationships anything and
everything give us a shout triple eight
eight two five five two two five i'm
john doloni joined here by george
campbell we're taking your calls on
money on life relationships we're here
to walk alongside you to get to the
messiness of this madness that's going
on out there we're here with you give us
a shout triple eight eight two five five
two two five let's go to jay in phoenix
hey jay what's going on
hey guys i just had a quick question for
you
um my wife and i we make about 120 000 a
year we currently have two auto loans
my wife's working at home indefinite
so my question is is should i
trade two auto loans in for one new auto
loan just to kind of consolidate and
reduce the payments per month
well i don't like the idea of just
moving the debt around is there any
chance that she might need a vehicle in
some kind of emergency situation
possibly just getting her a new vehicle
just to have and then just buying myself
on cash
or can you go a season with only one car
and sell one and pay off your debt
for for now possibly the only reason
that i'm even thinking about this is
because we've been trying to work on
buying a home our first home
um you know uh and we're just basically
waiting for that we know the markets for
the used value of europe for their use
vehicles way up in the of course the
home values are way up as well so we're
just trying to see what's best right now
yeah you're wanting to do a few things
at once here what are these cars worth
and what do you owe on them
um so
i owe about forty thousand
forty three and i have a nissan that's i
only owe seventeen thousand on and it's
it's worth 23 24 right now the word only
always is always a little trigger for me
i only owe seventeen thousand
dude
seventeen thousand dollars you owe how
much do you make what's your annual
salary
sorry you're breaking up on us jsp
there's a very strategic uh breakup
there on the phone
guys
your income alone is a 9000 combined
220. combine 120 and these cars are
worth close to
correct to get all together yes dude
that that's a lot i mean we that's our
parameter is 50 no more than 50 percent
of your income tied up in things with
motors in it and you guys are broke
what's your other debt portfolio how
much how much do you owe
uh currently uh not not too much we've
been paying down a lot of uh a lot of
other credit and things like that we'll
mail about four thousand dollars uh in
the world yet okay outside of those cars
right well let me tell you here's what i
would do if i was in your shoes and if i
was talking to my friend i would tell
you to sell
both vehicles and buy two very
reasonable cars if you even need two
reasonable cars worst case you sell both
vehicles and get one decent one
until you can
cash flow get out of debt and get get
your wife a car as well
and we're going to be the fun ruiners
here but brother you're not in a
position to buy a house yet in phoenix
you got to get no i 100 agree all right
good i want to get you get out of debt i
want you to have an emergency fund so
you can breathe
if i mean when not if something happens
on your new house and then you're going
to save up 10 to 20 of a down payment
before you get about buying anything
okay so we're talking a couple of years
here
and it's gonna be frustrating and
annoying and all that stuff but hang in
there okay you're playing a long long
game on this one if you sell these cars
and you said they're worth about 60k and
let's say you buy a 10 000 car
right that still leaves you with a nice
chunk of change
doesn't it you gotta pay this thing off
yeah once once you pay off the loans
what's left if you sold them no
really just a few credit cards and and
that's about it man that feels good i'd
be done i'd
i post i'd set them up today jay to sell
them i would be going all over town soon
who'd give me what going on vroom and
carvana and all those different websites
and see who's gonna give me the most
bang for my buck private on facebook
marketplace or craigslist man i want
these things out of my life this is just
too much car for you right now just get
a sandwich board and stand out in front
of a walmart and say no don't do that
don't do that don't do that but right
now these cars own you you don't own
them and so you'll get to that spot i
want you to but once you get that
emergency fund you start saving up for
that house man you're in that house you
got a reasonable payment on it now we
can talk about upgrading the cars there
you go let's go to max in orlando what's
up brother max how we doing
hey man how you doing good what's up how
can we help
hey so uh
at 27 years old i'm officially debt-free
uh congrats man
appreciate it i just got medically
discharged from the army of 10 years
and
appreciate appreciated so they gave me a
seventh check of 75 000 okay uh i paid
off all our debt i got 55k left in the
bank
uh the va gives me 4k monthly for my
disabilities which i can still work
they also paid off my student loans for
being uh total and permanent
so i i have i basically got my
bachelor's paid for for free very cool
and uh
we already own at home we're renting it
out we get about five dollar cash flow
from it monthly in north carolina i was
wondering what's what's so right oh so
we moved from north carolina down to
florida so
uh the only bills i have is probably
like a thousand dollars a month car
payment car insurance and phone bills
okay and uh we're living rent free right
now my mother she helps out with a lot
of us uh she has no issue with it please
wonder what's the next step what i do
with this 55 000 i've never really had
lump sum of money before yeah
what's the nature of your disability
brother
i just hope i had like four or five
surgeries from from jumps i did okay man
thanks for leaving it out there for us
yeah grateful for you
i appreciate it i was just wondering uh
some money's not an issue for me or not
i can still work and everything so i was
just wondering what's what's the we want
to buy a second home in florida so we're
just trying to figure out what's uh
what's the next move i know the first
move is to get a job obviously
uh
but what do i do with this 55 000 that's
in bank yeah it's a great question uh uh
you flew by something earlier you said
you've got a car payment
yeah it's at least it's a three year
lease
well you told me you were debt free and
i was really excited for you
and now i gotta backtrack
bro
what do you think elise is i don't i
don't i really don't consider can i have
kids so i like i think of a car as like
a reliable transportation i always have
a new car okay here's here's a good way
to look at debt if i stop paying what
happens if someone comes after me it's
called debt
you owe anyone anything for any reason
it is dead and brother i got two little
kids and i got an 06 and a 10.
and they got you they're we're gonna
ride them to the wheels fall off man and
i love my kids more than life itself and
they are just fine in those cars i don't
look cool
thankfully i'm already married and my
wife is a wears like really dark
sunglasses and so she doesn't wait i'm
good i'm not i'm not gonna no one's
gonna come after me and tell me how cool
i am but dude that's it's a debt and
it's a chain on you okay and we're about
solving for freedom here that's what me
and george are doing and they tell me
real quick about this house
why are y'all keeping a house that you
don't live in
uh because it's a good cash flow we paid
monthly 1300 on it and uh we rented out
for 2000 in north carolina okay you cash
flow 500 a month
yes so 6 000 a month is some
game-changing investment for you
dude you can do better than that you
could do better than that just investing
in retirement iras this is not great to
be a long distance landlord if i'm you
and you want to set yourself up for
freedom i would sell that thing i'd stop
being a long distance landlord i pack
all the money i could and i'd set myself
and my family up for freedom in our next
house that's what i would do yeah i'm
gonna pay off the call i'm gonna get out
of this lease i'm gonna buy the lease
out or turn the car back in we'll sell
this house i'm gonna take all that money
plus the 55 000. i'm gonna have an
emergency fund of three or six weeks and
then i'm gonna buy me my own place for
me and my family there in florida that
simplicity is making me breathe easier
john all around you hey thanks for your
service brother max absolutely we'll be
right back
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the ramsey show let's go
out to cara in h town houston texas
what's up cara
hi thanks for taking my call guys thank
you for calling what's up
well i feel like my family's in a
position that maybe some other americans
are in my husband is a nurse
and
we i was really hoping that his
exemption
for the vaccine would be approved and we
just found out last night that it was
denied
and kind of the cms um
my team mandate is everywhere and so
at the end of the month you know his
income will be no more in our health at
this point
and i'm just thinking are we looking at
a career change do you guys have any
advice i mean we
are debt-free but our health we have an
emergency fund um we've got three kids
who aren't even school age yet so like
there's a lot of emotion and thoughts
that are going on through our house
right now so we've got a lot to think
about yeah so number one you're right i
know lots of people are going through
all sorts of job transitions and are
staring this in the face and so
uh thanks for being brave and calling
and putting it out there for us to walk
through um so here's how i
make these decisions this is just the
matrix that i use right wrong or
indifferent and
i just wanna there is no way to talk
about
covet and vaccine mandates and job loss
without people losing their minds and so
that's fine
here's how i make these type of
decisions
i always want to back out of these
things and take the
air or the emotion and set it to the
side for a second those feelings are
real the emotion is real
but what are the facts in front of me
the facts are this
i have a principle or a value it could
be about mandates it could be about
being asked to steal at work it could be
it could be about anything
i have a set of core principles
and my employer is violating those
principles
so much so that i am opting to have no
job
that's my that's my stance that's my
platform that's my that's that's where
i'm sitting and come what may
i will have to
work 50 part-time jobs i'm gonna have to
go to another hospital i'm gonna have to
move i'm gonna have to do other things
but my values are that important
and almost always
unless there's just something
way out
i've got high respect for anybody who
says i've got a set of values that i
simply i can't i can't move forward on
this
right
so i want to take the emotion aside and
look at the reality the reality is you
guys have 30 days or a little less than
30 days before you're gonna have no
income
so let's take out the mandates let's
take out the frustration the anger
what are y'all going to do for food and
rent
and
transportation what are you going to do
and that's when you i think career
change is it time to go i think you put
all that stuff after you take care of
your four walls right you're going to be
able to keep your house you're going to
be able to keep your little kids fed
you're going to be able to keep the
lights and electricity running you can
be able to get to and from the grocery
store that that becomes where my initial
how am i going to solve for this
so what's your plan there
well we have taken a look at the budget
i work
um you know i make about twice as much
as my husband and and so we are we are
extremely extremely thankful great um
for that so when it comes to our four
roles you know maybe we're only taking
between we're kind of slimming
everything down and maybe we're only
taking between 500 and 1000 out every
month from our emergency fund and that
covers that that covers everything so
our four walls we're good nobody's to go
hungry
um you know we can put gas in the car
our health you know
you know we'll be paid
um we just we have big goals
yeah and here's the thing not by your
hand but in your lap
you didn't cause it yeah but you had a
values based decision and somebody
dropped something in your lap and they
called your bluff and you said cool i'm
sticking by our values whatever they
happen to be
and yeah so
i
i don't want you to make a practice of
living off the emergency fund but here
we are and so i think now is when you're
hustling that's not our intention that's
right that's right of course it's not
but now your husband's able to say
do i love nursing do i want to find a
place whether it's on a college campus
or at an elementary school or a travel
like do i love this this is what i want
to be doing and i just got caught up in
a in a mess that will go away at some
point or will reduce at some point or
may never change that right do i love
nursing do i love helping people do i
want to go back to school and get some
different credentials i think you're
you're in a position and it's a
fortunate position to ask that question
and then say what comes next and i'm
gonna hold my head up high anytime i
make decisions and i'm angry or i am
raged out i never make good choices i'm
out of this profession i quit this is
the
actually i love nursing i hate that this
thing is happening here where can i find
nursing where can i find human care
where can i find connection other places
and i'll get on that road and maybe
there's none maybe there's not i don't
know enough to i haven't kept close
enough uh tabs on it there may not be
any places left to go and it may be that
this is i've got to go do something else
but i think you can enter a season of
one month two months and figure it out
i'll give you a copy hang on the line
we'll give you a copy of our friend ken
coleman's book from paycheck to purpose
and it's just got some good exercises to
walk through it and say what do i
actually want to be doing and what i
actually love
um
is your family united in this decision
um my husband and i we are 100 on board
i can't say the same for you know some
extended families
kind of a mixed bag
made this decision a long time ago when
you know we're like what do we need to
put on this exemption that fits with our
family and what we believe and what we
have already set forth is how we believe
and feel and all that
um you know natural immunity is like not
a thing in the cms world they don't
really care that we have that um but yes
we are fully united we're supportive of
you know that decision and whatever it
means for us in the coming days i just
feel like it's uh i know my husband's an
extremely hard worker and he has never
been in the situation where his
job is
um
being taken from him you know from you
know and this is the decision that we
made just like if you were a poor
performer that's a decision you made
right well
it's there is something about
um
there's something about
knowing something's coming
and then it shows up
right and we are often caught off guard
by how much it hurts how scary it is we
knew it was common we knew this was
coming down the road and then it's here
i hear this a lot when i used to sit
with folks who had long-term illnesses
we know that granddad's going to pass
away and if you did but when he actually
passes away it's something else right
and people are caught off guard by that
so
don't be caught off guard by how off
guard you're gonna feel right
i want you and your husband to have a
regular practice if i were you i'd make
this a daily practice
three minutes
go i'm scared i'm kind of freaked out
i'm pissed off i'm angry about all this
or taking a job away that i love
and then you go and then you get your
three minutes and then all right what
are we gonna be about solving this today
i'm gonna make sure that we've got
purpose we've got a paycheck what do you
want to actually do with your life how
are you going to get back on the horse
and let's go down that road i'm just not
going to i'm not going to let anger and
emotion and rage take me over because i
know i'm going to make less
wise decisions when that happens yeah
and the only thing i'll add to that john
is he's got to be about the business of
getting to work clearly he's a hard
worker and he might have to swallow his
pride have some humility and go do jobs
that he would never otherwise do right
now but planning on using the emergency
fund like we talked about earlier is a
bad plan i want you to have use it
because you absolutely need it so if you
can avoid touching that that would be my
goal personally is to go well he can
work he can make an extra 500 to a
thousand bucks a month to help us avoid
dipping into the emergency fund while he
looks for something new while he figures
out what he really wants to do so that
would be my personal goal just adding on
top of that the financial part yeah and
and again i want to i feel like i'm a
broken record sometimes
nobody well they're talking about um you
know talking about work we're talking
about relationship issues we're talking
about investing
nobody it's it's a neurological thing
nobody makes good decisions when they're
in fight or flight when they are
consciously stewing they are living in
this rage and they're angry
i get it's real i get it's visceral i
get it hurts
and then you gotta set that down and say
okay what do i gotta do right now focus
on the future next steps that's right
i'm gonna choose optimism in a mess i'm
gonna choose it because why not right
because why not we'll be right back on
the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
this is the ramsey show
half of americans over 65 will need
long-term care and the average cost of
that care is 138
000
you've got to plan for the long-term
care needs now
but i talk to people all the time whose
quote-unquote plan is to let medicare
pay for it i got news for you people
medicare won't pay for everything that's
why i recommend long-term care insurance
for people aged 60 and over it helps pay
for nursing home care assisted living
and in-home care costs like medical
equipment help getting dressed and
eating and home modification so you can
get around safely in your house
that way you get to keep your
independence and your savings long-term
care insurance protects your family too
your spouse and kids won't have to bear
the financial and emotional burden of
caring for you and since you're not
using all your savings on long-term care
you'll be able to enjoy your retirement
years with your family and leave a
legacy that provides for them after
you're gone
our network of endorsed local providers
will help you understand your long-term
care insurance options and find the
right policy for you that's why they're
ramsey trusted because they'll put you
first no matter what so if you're over
60 it's time to connect with a trusted
elp and get your free long-term care
insurance quotes visit
ramseysolutions.com long-term care to
get started that's ramsay solutions.com
long-term care let's go out to ian in
amarillo texas the 806. what's up ian
hey what's going on guys how y'all doing
today excellent how are you
i am doing awesome great what's up so
so uh right now i'm 31 years old i'm
married my wife is pregnant but she's
not currently working congratulations my
income thank you
my income is about a 110 000 a year
and we are about 112 000 in debt
um what do you do not
i uh i work in the nuclear industry
oh yeah i know that over there is it
pantec over there
yes it is very cool man
and what's the what's the what's the
debt
um well most it's like 3 500 in credit
card debt we only have one credit card
um
i took like a 8 000 loan out on a ring
i owe
12 000 on a motorcycle i owe 65 000
on a truck
which is majority of our debt
and uh her student loans were about a
22 000.
okay what's your question
so i have about forty five thousand
dollars from my former uh employer in a
401k
i'm wondering if i should just pull that
out take the hit on it take the uh the
taxes and all that
and pay off a chunk of that debt or if i
should just roll it into a current
uh
401k or like another retirement plan i
don't really know what to do with that
money i feel like pulling it out and
paying off some debt would work but i
just don't know what the taxes would be
and you want me to talk to you like i
talked to my friend or do you want to
make you feel good you you get to choose
today
i want to know the honest truth what i
should do
ian you are living you are living the
west texas dream you got a great job you
got the big truck the big ring
you are you are you are west texas
through and through let them have it
george okay man
and you know me john i'm just not a car
guy but here's the thing man
you are making a terrible decision by
pulling this money out of this 401k
don't do it you're going to be taxed at
your tax rate plus the 10 penalty you
know all this and you're saying i'd
rather lose 35 of this money that could
make me a millionaire so i can keep my
big truck
that's what i heard
keep my big truck ian dude sell the
truck sell the motorcycle today sell the
motorcycles you're going to be a dad
dude you don't want to be riding on that
death trap right now
oh man i know it hurts truck you say
listen i drove out to snyder a few years
ago and bought a f-150
that was made before the american
revolution not really but it was old can
i can i hit you with another factor and
it wasn't cool and it got me where i
needed to go man
dude 70
of your income is tied up in things with
motors in it that are going down in
value every day you wake up
does that not make you angry i'm angry
you riled me up guys
it does here's here's a little little
spot i'm stuck in though
okay truck is i had a series of
stupid decisions
that led me to being about twenty
thousand dollars upside down in this
truck so the truck is only worth about
forty thousand dollars okay um
so oh like 65. so let's take a 65 000
mistake
okay
and let's say you go sell it and you get
40 grand how much do you still owe
oh 20. okay 25. 25. there you go
math i'm glad you're working in a
nuclear industry
it's not my strong suit again so you got
25 and then you go take a loan out for a
two thousand dollar
19 or 2 000 corolla to get you to and
from
and i know that car exists because i
sold it right before i moved to
nashville in your area so it's out there
somewhere
and it's going to get you to and from
now you don't owe 65 000
you owe 26.
okay and you've more than
you've cut your debt load in half just
there and then you sell that
your your big boy my bicycle
you sell that and now you got another
chunk of money to knock that thing off
you see what we're doing here
yeah yeah i see where we're going
and i dude i
there is not but anybody else in this
building that knows how bad this hurts
than me i get it what i'm asking you to
do
but here's what i'm asking you to
think about the legacy of this little
kid that's about to be born think about
the insecurity your wife feels knowing
that
that 70
of your household debt is depreciating
every day it's becoming less and less
value
what if you told your wife hey i've had
a
uh you married a guy that was like do
you have boots that have square toes on
them probably uh yeah i do of course you
do so i married a guy with cool jeans
and square toed boots in the big truck
and i'm going to change i'm going to be
the husband that's going to make sure we
are financially secure and safe
i'm going to drive goofy cars
but you watch what happens to our net
worth to our bank account and man
if she looks at you and says you will
not sell that truck i want to i married
a man with a big then you probably got
yourself a problem she's not gonna do
that
she's not like that no so what would she
do if you came at her with that hey i'm
so i've set us up in a hole and it's
time for me to change
what would she say what would she do
she uh she's awesome she really does
support me in any decision that we have
to make uh we had
really really big conversations about
money and stuff like that before we even
got married um
but it was just like i said a series of
stupid decisions that i made that led me
to sixty five thousand dollar truck
that's worth forty thousand dollars so
i'm pretty sure she would support it
um all right so as long as it's
something that's that we're safe in you
know like right now of course ice ice
and snow on the ground and it's been
snowing all day so she
hey dude looking rock some snow when's
that baby dude
uh august all right so me and george our
gift to you is we're going to give you a
year subscription to ramsay plus as a
wow baby gift but baby warming gift
that's that a thing that sounded weird i
don't know that you need your baby needs
to be any warmer but
hey it's our gift but listen you gotta
promise
two things that you will go through
every one of the fpu lessons the
financial piece university lessons in
that
series with your wife you'll watch them
together
and you'll talk to her and say how does
this make us feel how do you feel about
this what would this be like for our
family and then the second thing is by
the end of tomorrow you've got to put
one of those things up for sale you've
got to have it posted somewhere is that
cool
yeah yeah let's let's do it are you in
i'm i'm in we turned them around my man
dude
right now
hey you're going to be the only dude
rolling up to a nuclear factory on a
bicycle or driving a camry right
and you're going to be
absolutely you make too good of a salary
to be as broke as you are my brother you
just do i know i know you know what i
mean you make six figures in a in a part
of the country that the cost of living
is pretty low i want you to
[Music]
you work so hard man you're a smart
smart smart guy hey and by the way quit
beating yourself up we've all done
stupid stuff with money yeah we have a
single one of us you sound like a cool
guy i want to get a drink with you this
guy's awesome man come to nashville when
you're debt-free let's hear about it but
remember there's no shortcuts when it
comes to getting out of debt and bar
robbing your 401k that's a shortcut do
the hard work you're not scared of it
you got this and sell the motorcycle so
the big bike and the big truck we'll be
right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
this is the ramsey show taking your
calls about life and money triple eight
eight two five five two two five i'm
john dalone joined by george campbell
and we are here for you triple eight
eight two five five two two five let's
go out to ross in springfield missouri
hey ross what's going on
hey dr john and george thank you all for
taking my call you got it my brother
what's up uh me and my wife are
currently on baby steps four five and
six and we'll hopefully have our house
paid off by the end of next year
oh thank you all appreciate it very cool
i know i know you all say to buy a house
with payments less than 25 percent of
your income
but once you have your house paid off uh
what value of how should i have passed
that should i base it on a certain times
our income or a certain percentage of
our net worth is there a rule of thumb
you're saying if you're going to
purchase a new home after that yes okay
my house
are you looking for like an investment
property are you saying you want to
upgrade the house and sell your primary
uh just for primary house okay i mean i
would stick to those parameters my goal
for you would be to pay cash for any
upgraded house and no there's no
parameter if you're paying cash you can
buy two million dollar house if you pay
cash uh that's great it's a great part
of your
your net worth your retirement plan
because that home will appreciate and
you own every single cent of it
uh now i won't be mad at you if you if
you go get another mortgage and do the
same thing and and roll that into the
next one but i think it's a cool goal to
have personally to be able to pay cash
for that next one can i ask you ross
you've got it sounds like you'll have
worked
y'all have just busted it to get this
thing paid off
what would motivate you to go get a
mortgage again
uh well i wouldn't want to get a
mortgage again i just wanted to know you
know if i should have a more expensive
house for our income or you know if our
net worth gets higher if i should have a
house be a certain percentage of my net
worth
is there a house you have a in your mind
that you want to go get that you think
might be too expensive what's the root
of this goal not in
not in particular just out of
um i say people with a you know spending
a lot of money on houses and i hear
people you know that call in to spend a
lot on houses you know but i would
consider comparative income and i just
want to know you know if you all had a
certain ratio that you went by i'll tell
you this in our millionaire study that
we did what we found is that most of the
millionaires their net worth looked like
this about two-thirds of that was in
investments it was their 401k it was
their ira over a lot of time and
consistency and about a third was their
home value so that's a parameter that's
not to say that if yours is different
that you're doing anything wrong my goal
is for you to be a baby steps
millionaire and whatever that looks like
is awesome and let me let me
i'm not poking at you i'm just um um
we're friends now right ross
you bet we're friends
um
our friend rachel cruz says
comparison is the thief of joy
and i know this is folklore at this
point but um
uh i just lost his name berkshire
hathaway what
warren yeah warren okay
our friend warren warren buffett yeah
still lives in his friend still lives in
the same house
and so what i want you to do when
considering where you're going to live
say do we love our house and do we like
it and it's paid off it can be enough i
am good yeah it's that magic word my
friend dr mark phillips taught me about
the magic word of enough when's enough
enough and man just because somebody
makes the same amount of money or really
the other way around you make as much as
they do and you think well i guess i
should get that car and i guess i should
you know me and george we're neither of
us are car guys and people hassle us
around here for the cars that we drive
i guess where i want to go i'm not a car
guy i'm i like it right and would it be
cool to have something else yeah it'd be
awesome man i like driving fancy things
but right now i'm i'm good he's good
consider
i want you to be content with where
you're at don't feel like you need to
get another house just because you make
x dollars what's this house going to be
worth once you pay it off ross just your
guess
um
i'd say probably one and a quarter
wow
25 000. no 125 000 sorry oh it's like
one and a quarter million dude boy ross
okay so 125 000 house what do you have
in investments
um right now probably uh 75
75 000 in investments how old are you
34. 34. okay dude you got your whole
life ahead of you yeah man you're just a
youngster how much do you make
uh me and wife combines probably 75 a
year
awesome brother you have a paid off
house do you like the house does it meet
your needs
yeah we bought it when we got married it
was a new house and
i guess she's content with it i am i
just want to make sure i didn't need to
upgrade you know as
investments grow since then start
putting more into investments now if you
find a place to live and you owe nobody
anything on it and you are
you've got joy
you have won you got people in your life
you'll love what you clearly do you have
won you've won good for you you start to
enjoy those stains and a little little
crack in the drywall because it's my
crack yeah it's right stains right can't
come at me i own it exactly good stuff
let's go to corey out in salt lake city
what's up cory
hi how are you guys thanks for having me
up thank you what's up um
so i have a question about uh it has to
do with a job offer and my side business
so about um
about a year ago i started a side
business where i i manufacture
um cable assemblies uh in my garage and
over the past year
um it has grown quite a bit and
um we ended up
making quite a bit of money last year i
didn't i didn't hear what you were
making what were you making you say
cable assembly
yeah cable assemblies you got custom
cable assemblies okay um
for the electronics industry and we
and then i have a day a day job as well
and i made altogether about 120 000 last
year between my day job and and my side
business right um but i
uh just recently got a job offer um from
a company here in utah that is in the
same field they don't they don't do the
same thing but they manufacture
a
device that tests
cables and um
one of the stipulations for
me to work work there is to um either
sell my side business or
transfer into somebody else's name so
that there isn't a conflict of interest
between the companies and so i just
wanted to
talk that through with somebody and and
find out so we have a very similar thing
here
so
if um i didn't but if i had written
books
before i joined this team
part of me joining this team was
transferring ownership of my
intellectual property to this team
that's just part of it because
all of a sudden i can try to sell books
out of my car
if dave says hey this is a great book
and he gets behind it it's going to sell
way more copies right so so there's a
give and take there um this sounds like
a very similar situation and i what i
would say is don't over like we talked
about this on an earlier call don't over
emotionalize it this is just a set of
facts do you want this job for this
amount of money and here's the
stipulation you got to wear pants you
got to tuck your shirt in and you got to
sell your side business right and if you
think of it that way then you can say
okay am i invested in this side business
what can i sell it for is it worth the
money i'm going to be making is it more
stable long-term right or do i want to
be an entrepreneur and start this up i
think those are all simple questions i
wouldn't over
um over
over dramatize the the the job
stipulations
what's the job offer how much are they
offering
um so they're offering uh it's 75 000 a
year but they're within the company
there's a um
there's kind of a ladder to move up it's
within a new department that could be
um
that could become a bit bigger and then
i could move up within that department
okay do you like your side hustle you do
that
i i do i like it and
when you you spoke earlier about
emotions when i when i think about it uh
it actually makes me quite emotional
yeah um
let that speak to you then okay
if i say hey don't get emotional about
this and you go all right cool you're
right i just need to sell this that's a
big signal if i say hey don't get
emotional about this and you say
no this is my baby right now we're back
to the old solomon prov like now we're
back to i'm not cutting that baby in
half right then i just wanted to live
like so that may be a big signal if
you're not gonna see a big financial
increase you're gonna give up a dream
something you've been building hang on
to it man hang on to it you're clearly
good at what you do somebody else will
have a job offer for you if that's what
you want to do i like to thank the guys
in the booth especially james childs
a good friend george campbell we will be
back right here on the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions from nashville tennessee this
is the ramsey show where we talk about
your money your life your relationships
your mental health anything and
everything i'm john doloni joined here
by george campbell and we are taking
your calls live at triple eight eight
two five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five
five two two five whatever is going on
in your life give us a shout kelly's
sitting by the phone waiting for you
let's go to andrew in flint michigan hey
andrew what's going on
hey you guys how you doing great how are
you
i'm doing well hey i got a quick
question for you guys my i was recently
alaska
um
you just cut out you said you were
offered a job in alaska
yeah can you hear me better now yes what
are you doing in alaska
all right so i offered a uh entry level
sales position
and i'm currently in mid-level supply
chain
now the sales position has a base plus a
guaranteed commission which
adjusting for the cost of living gives
me a three
thousand dollar raise
for the first two years
uh the thing is this would be kind of a
temporary move recent adventure for my
wife and i um
i'm kind of wondering if if we if it's a
bad career move to go to an entry-level
sales job from a mid-level supply chain
and then number two if we do take the
job
do we rent or sell our house
oh so
you said a couple of things here let's
let's just kind of separate them out
number one this is a three thousand
dollar move
you can go work at uh lyft for
a month and make that so let's move the
money off to the side this is not a
financial move
yep for sure
multiple times in my career when i was
moving to a bigger company a bigger
university is what i did i would take a
decrease in
title sometimes even a decrease in money
for a different opportunity or for the
opportunity for something bigger or i
was at a bigger fancier school and you
see what i'm saying so there was a
strategy there was it was a strategic
move
um to take a
what looked on paper like a demotion but
it really wasn't long term right
and so
that doesn't sound like what you're
doing here it sounds like what you're
doing here is you and your wife just
want to go have a adventure
and how old are you guys
26 do you got little ones
nope so that was kind of our motivation
so sales was something i wanted to get
into um
up front but the
the idea of going to alaska was kind of
an adventure before we had kids and
wanted to be back in michigan and about
two two and a half years yeah um and
this was kind of an opportunity to do
that just it's kind of a
step backwards and is it a dumb decision
i i mean i don't think it's a matter of
is it dumb i'm just wondering do you
want to be there's like 17 questions
here do you want to be in sales long
term
i i believe so yes
you believe so versus supply chain
you're like i'm done with supply chain
world it was too crazy this year i'm out
yeah
sure
but here's there's a lot going on as far
as the it's a temporary move so you're
saying i'm i'm gonna come back and so
you're gonna tell your employer hey i'm
gonna be here for two years and peace
out
yes the hope was to transfer within the
company back save locations all over the
place okay um
see but again that's speculative and
that's that's two years away i mean i
think you got to look at this
like we want to go for an adventure this
is a funded adventure is what it is and
it could turn out to be something great
is that right
yep i mean i guess if what are you going
to be selling
this would be
warehousing solutions
where so it's still in your world with
supply chain yep okay
i mean if you're driven you want to move
up in this world and you want to stay in
sales for a while or you come back and
you go back to supply chain it sounds
like those are all on the table so this
doesn't sound like a fatal decision
either way you go to alaska and you hate
it and you go all right we're gonna go
back to michigan
now if you're gonna be there for a short
period of time i don't know that i'd
bother with the hassle of selling and
then trying to buy something new unless
real estate in michigan is is easy to
get right now and you can get a sweet
place
i don't know what it's like it's kind of
it's kind of crazy right now okay if you
sold your house could you
could you do real well
uh i could if the the problem was
selling i mean i would make probably 60
to 70 grand on it okay what would you do
if you kept it
uh if i kept it i would rent it out so
um
the mortgage is less than 600 bucks a
month not including tax insurance okay
uh we only owe 30 grand on it so we
would pay it off while we were over
there okay um do you have somebody that
could manage it for you because being a
landlord out of alaska may be a
challenge
yeah that was the so we would i would
have to look into a management company
okay um i do have friends that said they
would help out i really don't want to
depend on anybody yeah get them get a
management getting your buddy to wake up
at 2 a.m to go fix the water heater is
bad you're going to lose a friend over
there especially when you're in alaska
dodging bears and not really i love
alaska it's awesome
i mean i can't here's the thing
we live in a culture now where couples
are dropping out of the workforce to get
in an rv and do nothing and
like i just want money to fall from the
sky and deposit into my account i
shouldn't have to work whatever you've
got a job lined up it's not going to
further you financially unless you just
crush the sales right and i hear in your
voice you don't think you're going to
get out there and dominate it right
yeah it's a new business so my concern
is one's a cultural difference
a whole lot different than automotive um
and then do a time new sales so that was
my uh i think i could do well i just
don't think it'll be a
high volume high dollar sales okay in
terms of commission do you have a
contract of some sort that you're not
gonna get out there you're going to quit
a good job that you have right now
you're going to get out there and get
let go in three months
uh no so they they do
not from a letting go standpoint they
want a one year commitment because
they're giving me 10 000 to move towards
moving expenses yep um so i figured i
was kind of safe for that first year at
least
um but no there's nothing preventing
them from letting me go okay and your
wife's on board 100
yep she is um
she's kind of more for it than i am
because i'm a little worried about
uh career trajectory at this point um so
i'd say hey you're 26. are you a hard
worker
yes you're good at what you do
yep you're not afraid of
change i'm terrified to change it
so yeah don't actually
you know what i think you should do
if you want to not be terrified of
change you should quit your job and move
to alaska for this point yes this is
exposure therapy at its finest
um here's the thing you're 26 if you go
out there and make a tear and this was a
terrible move you hate sales it's
i don't know if you've heard but it's
cold um you don't want to get eaten on
the way to the market whatever's going
to go go up you say this is a terrible
decision you're 26 you come back and
you're 27 you're gonna work hard you're
gonna figure it out i don't have any
concern about that if your wife's on
board and y'all are young you got no
kids you got no responsibilities holding
you down other than this perceived
career trajectory whatever the heck that
means here's the thing i work on
on a radio show brother and my career
trajectory was working in colleges so
who knows we're live 20s are the time to
figure this out yeah i say go for andrew
do you have any debt
uh just the mortgage okay
good spot call from alaska oh that'll be
fun there's oats military academy there
too if you're a bill and ted's fan but
hey enjoy alaska my brother it's gonna
be a fun fun ride talk to you soon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsey show triple eight
eight two five five two two five taking
your calls on marriage
money
life all of it triple eight eight two
five five two two five
this is big time john you know what you
know what's coming up
what's big time you know what's coming
up don't you
you gotta be more specific you've got
your super bowl money and marriage with
rachel cruz coming up february 11th the
live stream this has become world renown
people go crazy for this our team does
an incredible job making it a cool
experience for date night and you talk
about this a lot how people people do
valentine's the wrong way
a lot and it's we're gonna go get
bloated on a big meal
and uh talk about normal stuff that we
normally would talk about and then go
home bloated
too bloated to have any kind of intimacy
we're tired you have a different kind of
valentines but this is it's a lot of
bloated a lot of blood
but tell us about what what happens
during this livestream
so a couple things one is
i
i'm trying to find silver linings in the
last 24 months 36 months
and if there's one it's that i am no
longer letting a
a
uh a grocery store or a corner market or
a greeting card company tell me how i'm
going to
better love my wife i'm gonna i'm opting
out of that system we got a few years
where you couldn't go out to dinner or
you could but whatever i'm done right
and so what i'm going to do this year is
what i'm going to look at my wife i'm
going to look at myself say what do we
need what do we actually want to do and
that's where rachel and i we're coming
to your house in a live stream event
we're going to be talking about marriage
we're talking about sex we're gonna be
talking about money we're gonna be
talking about things that we're hearing
on our shows that i'm reading in the in
the literature they're hearing all over
the country that couples are struggling
with it's gonna be hilarious it's gonna
be fun and you don't have to leave your
house right it's 20 bucks we're gonna
save you some money i know times are
tough in millions of homes across the
country we're just gonna like no more
going out just because you have to or in
your case george no more bloating so
much so i'm a little die it doesn't take
much that is true that's two pieces of
pizza for you man
give me a break we are stay puft
marshmallow but hey um i think it's
gonna be a great event maybe we're gonna
have a blast and what's cool a lot of
people go well february 11th i'm not
sure what my plans are that night what's
really cool is that for that same 20
bucks they have 48 hours of access to
the recording
and that is total so if you can catch on
the 12th 13th that's great and here's
what's awesome
two awesome things one if you're a
ramsey plus member you get this for free
right it's 20 bucks otherwise but if you
are a ramsey plus member you get it for
free so just log in and go ahead and
register
the other cool thing is this
this is on friday night it's on
valentine's day weekend
valentine's is actually on the 14th a
couple days later so you get to go to
this thing it's like a mini retreat in
your home that's actually fun
and then you get to practice this stuff
for a couple of days leading up to
your super bowl right this may this
isn't really my super bowl but i like no
i don't do sports analogy john you know
that you were close but it really is one
of my favorite events i i get to watch i
used to host some of it which was a
blast and now i get to watch it from
home with my dog
and less judgment from you because last
time we brought my dog into the studio
this isn't a uh
this isn't a pet owner
we should do a pet owner's event that's
a good idea james is going to mark that
down
we absolutely should never do that let's
go to julie in springfield illinois hey
julie what's up
hi there can you hear me absolutely
what's up hey so i got married um this
is a second marriage uh so we got
married about three months ago and i
well i say i own my house i have a
mortgage on my house
and my new husband wants to give me some
money to put towards that and um
you know
try i'm just trying to figure out
how to split this up and what we need to
do and i really don't want to refinance
because i talked to my bank the other
day i've got a really good rate i mean
i've got a 3.0 rate on a 15-year loan
with 12 years left to pay for it so my
banker said
i would stick with where you are because
i'm paying a little extra anyway every
month so
so why do you need to refinance what was
the purpose you're trying to get him on
the loan are you trying to
have him buy it i don't know if i need
it
yeah i yeah i don't know what i need to
do so that he can be
he said he can give me like a lump sum
of money but
what would be the appropriate thing to
how much money would be fair you guys
aren't business partners
what is your husband no i just don't
want to be like just give me money or
you know what i mean i i don't care if
he gives me money at all okay here's the
thing
it's just one giant pool of money once
you're married right you're going to
combine accounts
yes you already are married have you
combined accounts
we have not
okay that's step number one yeah so you
you have a well before that you got a
pronoun issue right and as dave says you
are all french now it's wee-wee right
so right it's not he's gonna give me
some of his money for for some of my
equity it is
we joined forces
and so if he's got a chunk of money
we are putting this down to pay this
house off together
okay okay and if you love him enough to
join with him in marriage
then
you would love him enough to say if i
die and we have this house that we own
together
you are the sole beneficiary of this
place in my will
okay and that way you can avoid a
refinance at this point
okay so i and and just keep it under my
name then i don't like that but i do
understand you know what there is a way
um you want to add them to the title
yeah there's a way to do that and i
don't
i haven't had to do it so i can talk to
my banker about it yeah walk them
through it but say i just got married i
want to add my husband to this um
without putting him on the loan
okay okay that you don't need to put him
on the loan just so you're both on the
hook
it's fine okay you're in this thing so
that that's what i would do if i was in
your shoes you both have ownership of
the home legally uh but we're paying off
this mortgage together do you guys have
any debt
other than the mortgage that's the other
thing i was going to talk to you no my
car's paid off his truck is paid for so
i mean i use a credit card just to to
get
um airline points you know what i mean
so to julie how much money do you make
i make like 84 000 a year you can't
afford to see it on an airplane
oh i know
truly you get free tickets you're not
winning
i get a free you know
little i have but i pay it off at the
end of the handed chucky cheese because
i gave him 20 bucks that doesn't mean
i'm winning it's an automatic payment i
just have it set up to automatically pay
the bill story for another day i'm not
going to fight you on it but so you guys
don't have any debt
we don't but but but he keeps telling me
julie you are in debt you are in debt
because of this house we've got to pay
this mortgage off i like the spirit yeah
you know what i feel that same way i got
a mortgage right now i feel the exact
same way okay okay so
it's a good tax right i mean it's a good
tax no no no julie
i wonder i really want to be friends
julie
hey we are friends we are friends you're
trading a dollar for a quarter and
thinking you won there's a lot of areas
right yeah the money you spend in
interest just look at your at your tax
return yes the money you spend to
interest versus the tax write-off you're
losing and unless you itemize which very
few people are doing now you don't even
get the deduction
right right so here's what we're doing
we are going to look at our budget we're
going to start
og with the baby steps y'all
don't owe anybody any money so you're
going to go past baby step one pass baby
step two do you have an emergency fund
[Music]
three to six months is three to six
months is worth of expectations
household expenses not his expenses not
your experience expenses as we say in
texas
that's right and then you're going to
put that in a savings account a
high-yield savings account you're not
going to touch it it's just going to be
there in case one of you gets laid off
the roof caves in whatever happens and
it's not
it's not if it's when right so you're
going to put that in account and then
y'all are both gonna breathe and you're
gonna smile and then you're gonna look
at how much money y'all have in your
other cash accounts and you're gonna pay
this house off you're gonna pay your
house okay
and get it done with and then y'all are
going to ride off into the sunset
together
i love him and you're going to have a
paid for ride into that sunset without
having to rely on your credit card
points
right julie you're so right i'm so dumb
no you're not no you're not you're not
you know what you are you're absolutely
normal and this show is about weird
people we're just really weird it's
about doing things different it's about
doing things
that are gonna put you towards freedom
not towards temporary happiness but
towards
freedom
that was a fun roller coaster john i
liked you we landed we got like i want
to go again hang on the line julie we're
going to give you a copy of dave's new
book baby steps millionaires because
that's your next step when you cut off
your credit cards we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsey show triple eight
eight two five five two two five taking
your calls on life and money in
relationships
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
george what are you working on over
there well here's the thing john a lot
of people have been
worrying about inflation incessantly
it's america's biggest problem right now
inflation's at about seven percent
highest it's been in many many years and
people are feeling the pinch this is a
real thing if you've been to the gas
pump you've been at the grocery store
you've been to chipotle you're like why
is my chicken bowl now ten dollars i
didn't even get the guac john i didn't
get that would have been another 11 this
is insane and so i've been digging into
just kind of helpful ways i like to call
them hacks you hate the word hacks
because they're not hacks it takes a
little bit of work it takes a little bit
of research know-how time effort energy
so hacks just make me feel like it's
easy even though it's not that's a very
millennial approach i i accept that is
where we stand so i wanted to give the
people out there some tips especially
around grocery shopping because the
stats are showing us people are spending
you know it used to be 292 a month now
it's 350 a month yeah on groceries and
so there's some ways that i've i've been
living this way before it was cool i was
the original hipster when it came to
frugality and so there's a lot of ways
people are overspending when it comes to
groceries eating out is a whole other
thing right when it comes to that meat
really expensive right now i'm not going
to tell people to go eat tofu because we
live in a society john
because we don't hate chips this used to
be a real country i'm not eating that
stuff
but here's the thing one of the biggest
ways uh people overspend is like we talk
about college choice as one of the
biggest ways to make college affordable
grocery store choice
man that's a game changer some of y'all
shopping at whole foods or whole
paycheck whatever you want to call it
that's a budget buster right now
maybe we try out aldi
no it's not the fanciest store you got
to put the quarter in the cart it's very
old-timey and fun you have to put a
quarter in the car at a quarter to get
the cart and then you get the
quarterback when you put the cart back
oh just in case you get it's an
efficiency thing no it's an efficiency
thing they don't have to have a cart
person you are the car you are the car
person they charge you you know 10 cents
for a bag they save some money that way
anyways you can get some great prices
there to get all your necessities i'm a
big fan of trader joe's if you have one
in your area i can fill up a whole
little buggy at trader joe's and spend
less than 100 bucks you can have a
shopping spree and it's a it's a great
deal but another thing people need to do
is buy generic
and this is offensive to some people so
don't take away my oreos absolutely
offended right now you're like
what do you want me to get sugar rounds
you want me to get the far out fruities
instead of fruity pebbles that's exactly
right but here's the truth john most of
those products are made in the same
factories in the same lines with the
same ingredients you can buy the look
next to the cheerios and you buy the
just the cellophane bag of oat o's right
you know it comes in the bag you get
worried you have to get a box that's
right like it feels a little less secure
and stable i will say milk in a bag is
disconcerting not going to have it i
just want it and a carton but that's a
big way people can save is going generic
uh i know there's some deal breakers
there like toilet paper i'm going name
brand i'm sorry i have trust issues
deodorant not i'm not uh i'm not hedging
on that one you're not going with the
with the dollar general branded i am a
snob when it comes to deodorant you
smell great i appreciate that it's
working thank you another thing to do is
buy things in bulk that you naturally
would eat a lot of right so buying a
huge bag of rice from costco that could
be a great deal that's going to feed
your family for a long time
but people assume that buying in bulk
means a better deal and the truth is it
doesn't here's what i want you to do
it's a quick fun little math experiment
you take your phone out when you're at
the grocery store
divide the price by the ounces
now you're asking people to do work
george and i just want to go to the
grocery store they're not really hacks
are they john sounds like you're making
me do math yes but that math is going to
make your life better because you're not
going to feel inflation as much i have a
six-year-old i mean sixth grade son and
he working through math and he asked the
other day when am i ever gonna use this
and now you're telling him in the
grocery store yep i'm telling hank buddy
there's hope for you they're embarrassed
you will use this i think that's
disconcerting not the pythagorean
theorem but just basic math uh this is
so do the math on those ounces don't
assume it's a good deal because it's at
the wholesale club and you're buying it
in bulk that's a big one and there's
this new thing called shrink flation
that is driving me crazy personally
so if your your breakfast bars used to
be one and a half ounces oh yes is that
what it's called yes now
they're charging the same price but they
shrunk it down to one ounce instead of
one and a half ounces i opened a bag of
something recently and i've i thought
it was all air i looked i'd like look in
and say you grew yeah it's amazing it's
a big friendly giant like the bfg what
is happening so it's called shrink
flation shrink-flation it's a real thing
yeah and companies are doing this to
save money without changing their price
because if you go well my breakfast bars
were you know i like lara bars we like
those we eat those and you go it used to
be five bucks well now larabars shrunk
the ounces and charged the same five
dollars so that you never notice you're
none the wiser john you're just a little
more hungry this is how they get you
they got me so there's a lot of ways
obviously meal planning but let me tell
you meal planning is a lot for a lot of
people it just feels too aggressive so i
like to say start with foods that you
enjoy that you're willing to eat because
if you're not willing to eat it you know
what happens it goes in the trash and
that's how inflation really gets you you
don't even eat the stuff you bought
because you thought you were going to be
in the mood for kale salad
classic scenario nobody's in the mood
for and then you go we're getting pizza
tonight that's right well
i i think it's important to also say and
i know this people are going to roll
their eyes and say oh my gosh you're
giving leftovers our thing
and don't be above leftovers i'm a big
fan of leftovers
they're huge in our house but um i know
that can be offensive and if you hate
leftovers become a better cook
and then you'll like leftovers it's
amazing how that works shots fired yep
coming at you america there's a whole
bunch of folks out here from chick-fil-a
you guys have done a great job keeping
the prices down so way to go guys big
fan of jake fly i've got my own
chick-fil-a hacks that i'll share it
another time but uh i like to go budget
friendly my wife does not her meal
somehow is like 48 dollars at
chick-fil-a mine's like four dollars i'm
getting the kids meals oh i didn't go if
you want to toy for the ice cream right
they understand yeah no i was with you
that one time yep john saw me order a
kids meal and i was in the car with him
and they thought i was his child
they thought man
don't see a lot of middle schoolers for
the full beard but we'll go with it
here's what it comes down to do a little
bit of math to figure out what is this
meal actually costing me does it cost me
20 per person because that's not a good
way to fight inflation but if i can get
it down to you know three four five
dollars that's a great deal and let's
just call it out like we can we laugh
joke
we we joke and we have a good time
i know that there are people who are
really hurting with the with the food
prices oh absolutely so hard man yeah
and things were already compressed and
tough and tight and millions of people
looking for jobs trying to move jobs
people
this is a messy time man and so i just
want to acknowledge it sometimes there's
moments you know when you work working
people's mental health and your work
people's money
like there's i don't have an instant
solution for you yeah other than to say
i'm sitting here with you i'm sorry and
that's what i mean my solution is let's
get creative and let's make it kind of
fun yeah and at least then it takes a
little bit of that sting away and you
feel like man this kind of what are what
other areas can we do this in another
one is gas that's another thing people
are worried about and you know i use an
app called gas buddy they're not a
sponsor but if you're listening awesome
app that shows me the cheapest gas in my
area and usually it's the wholesale
clubs huh i don't know that sam's at
costco and so those are great ways to
just do a little bit of math but don't
go to the gas station 48 miles away to
save two cents a gallon
like also do the math on that and go
that's not worth it i'm saving 20 cents
to go an extra 20 miles yeah don't do
that either very cool or stop driving
that's a good way to do it too carpool
or carpool a big fan of that a lot of
people that work here at ramsey in my
neighborhood and sometimes i'll just hit
your ride that's hey that to me is where
i like that i like to see communities
come together and say we got some local
challenges what are some local solutions
to some of these challenges we're going
to have people over once a month back in
when i had a group of friends we had an
event called rotisserie where we just
rotated that's the cheesiest name ever i
know but
we would just have once a week everybody
would take their leftovers out and bring
them over and it'd be half a bottle of
wine
yeah it was an old-school potluck and we
just rotated houses the rules were no
one cleans up
we're not like there's laundry in the
floors longer than the floor we want to
hang out and we're going to clean our
fridges out and these are folks that
were way better off financially than me
it wasn't about necessity at that point
it was just about community yeah and it
turned into something that was great
when it financially for us all too right
yeah and this will all blow over so
we're not saying this is your new life
and you have to shop at this new store
and you have to get gas over this is
just to help you guys out during this
time so that you have a little bit more
margin in your budget and that's why we
teach the baby steps by the way because
if you're in debt inflation is hitting
you a lot harder than when you've got
three to six months of expenses sitting
in a savings account you've got no one
you don't know anyone anything
you can sleep at night not worrying
about the extra 20 cents at the pump and
this is gonna blow over and inflation
will regulate back down they'll do
something else to
but don't let intentionality go by the
wayside yeah
i love i love the idea even if it's for
a few cents here a quarter here a couple
dollars here
intentional let this be the moment you
say i'm sorry being intentional how i
spend my money whether it's on a bag of
rice or for a car or for a home or
anything in between a lot of wisdom
there we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
the scripture today is psalms 145 15-16
the eyes of all look to you and you give
them their food at the proper time you
open your hand and satisfy the desires
of every living thing
john bunyan says you have not lived
today until you have done something for
someone who can never repay you
i like it say that one more time
you have not lived today until you have
done something for someone who can never
repay you john bunyan
i love that man we live in such a
networking roi and what can this
relationship do for me and that one
just do stuff for people who can't repay
you it's incredible way to go man all
right find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window covering
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use promo code
ramsey to get the best deal rules and
restrictions apply today's question
comes from vanessa in alabama
she says i've been listening to your
show at work which is almost all the
time you've helped me realize that it's
possible to get my head above water and
maybe i won't have to live like this
forever my question is do you have any
suggestions for preventing burnout when
literally working six to 14 hours per
day
six to seven days a week when i don't
work due to being exhausted and worn out
i stress about my debt how do i get out
of this cycle that's such a great
question so
most of the time when folks are
struggling with burnout
there's a couple of things here one
people get burned out when they feel a
sense of futility
i am running and i'm getting nowhere
right
and so there's something important about
keeping progress notes
do you know we see those people make the
charts and they have like the
temperatures where they're gauging the
debt my wife and i when we were paying
off our six figures for the student
loans we had uh those like chains that
we made out of construction paper and we
wrote each loan on them and my son was
involved and we hung it in our bedroom
and we tore one off every month so we
got to see it coming and it felt
frustrating and but but i got to see the
progress right
so one is that sense of futility the
other is this stress and anxiety about
the debt
and so often we stress about a thing
we try to solve it by going after the
thing even harder
i want you to think of stress maybe like
a teeter-totter and
when you feel something stressful over
here
come all the way over here and do some
other things
so the nagaski sisters wrote a great
book called burnout they talk about
man if you're feeling like this type of
i can't get it out of my head it's
looping go work out
go sleep go be with people go have
community right go do some of these
other things that your body is going to
relax and chill and
come back to this plan right you're
working hard let's make no mistake you
are working really hard and this is for
a short period of time this is finite
you are sprinting for your life and we
all go through seasons when we have to
live like this
i'm in one of those seasons right now
right about to launch a book we're
running and running and running running
it's busy it's exhausting but it's for a
season and my wife and i talked about it
my kids and i talked about it i've
talked about with a few of my friends
this is a season and it's going to be
this way for the next four or five
months and then we're going to be able
to breathe right so there's something
about the finality to it where are we
going am i taking care of my body and
things over here
and
when you find yourself stressing out
about a particular thing about
stretching about my debt
i want you to write down
i'm working hard to solve it like i want
you to be intentional getting the
thought out of your head and being able
to look at it with some distance on it
and writing writing a note to yourself
i'm really doing well i'm working hard
on this thing that you are about to be
gone from my life right
be
be intentional about your positive
self-talk right yeah so there's a couple
things you can do there but at the end
of the day
just make sure you've got some markers
if you're in the gym and you're trying
to lose weight if you are trying to get
out of debt i don't care what you're
trying to do make sure you you keep some
sort of progress record with yourself so
that you can
measure it but more importantly so you
can not ever fall into that futility
trap yeah humans require that sense of
progress which is why we talk about
behavioral psychological stuff more than
math around here absolutely but there is
a there is a piece of this where maybe
you do need to get tactical and write
down a reverse engineer and say all
right i got 50 dollars in debt i make
seventy thousand busting my butt right
now what is this going to look like okay
four thousand dollars a month for this
long i can pay it off here's my date i'm
gonna celebrate here's what i'm gonna do
when i become debt-free here's what i'm
gonna do to celebrate i'm gonna get my
friends we're gonna go on a trip
whatever that looks like dangle that as
the carrot in front of you so that you
have that why the vision around it but
man and you brought up a great point
little wins huge
right little wins are humongous
celebrate every thousand or two thousand
to pay off that's right every time you
pay off a credit card take yourself out
to dinner right
and or every time you pay off something
don't take yourself out to dinner that's
going to get you further in debt but do
something right
um
find a way to celebrate have some
friends or whatever that looks like for
you but little wins celebrate along the
way i love it great question all right
let's go to nolan in riverside hey nolan
what's going on
hey guys how's how's it going we are
awesome how about you
good good so i have a sort of a
decision to make
um
so i am um
looking at schools um i'm currently i'm
24 years old um my fiance is 23 years
old we are getting married in may
congratulations so she'll be my wife
thank you thank you so she'll be my wife
in may um i'm finishing up my master's
degree right now um and i should be
finished by april so right before the
wedding awesome i want to go into an edd
program an educational doctorate program
sure starting in august
but she wants to also
go back to school get her master's
degree also starting in august
um the problem is with the finances um
we we're just like unsure if it's the
right decision um in baby steps we're in
step three um we have no debt um i'm
paying for school cash flowing it per
class and that's what the plan would
like to do when we
um start in august or to fall
um
this sounds like a perfect opportunity
for a death match
yeah
it's like
no doubt
i i want us both to go um
it's just
we don't have an emergency like uh three
to six months of emergency fund sure we
only have a thousand dollars saved up um
you know the wedding honeymoon all that
stuff is gonna take most of our expenses
what's the epd going to get you nolan
what are you getting at edd it's going
to be
in public health so right now i'm
getting my master's degree in healthcare
administration yep and where you work at
edd in public health where are you
working
i do clinic i do clinical research okay
so for a university or for a private
company
a private company okay yeah
so what will that edd get you right away
yeah so it would actually get me nothing
right away um long term it could mean
that i can have a higher position in my
field um project manager ctm vice
president how old are you
i'm 24. okay yeah you told me that all
right so here's a common thing that i
see especially when i was working i i
sat on dissertation committee i would
review dissertations i worked with
doctoral students a lot okay so
here's a thing that i see that is real
common and you can avoid it all
is somebody going through
getting their bachelor's degree going
into their master's degree and then
going straight into a doctorate program
and here's what happens when you get out
with a doctorate you're 24 now so you're
gonna be 28 you'll have four years
experience you will be credentialed to
run the whole operation wherever you are
but you won't have the wisdom or 15
years or 10 years experience that it
would take to run that operation so
you'll find yourself in some sort of no
man's land
where you'll have a whole bunch of debt
and nobody in their right mind would
hire you just because you have a
certificate they want you to have the
experience and that credential is really
important so i don't undermine it i got
a couple of them myself
but you're gonna find yourself in a no
man's sleep what i'd love to see you do
is take two years after a post masters
and work like mad
learn everything become the go-to person
there take people out to coffee learn
how this thing works get really into the
research but not only the research part
but the politics part the funding part
the grant part all that stuff spend your
time there and let your wife go to
school
and then when she's done
then y'all can decide all right what's
next for us when it comes to graduate
school and that way you don't have to
worry about the money parts you don't
get all wound up in who's going and i'm
not gonna go i think it's a great moment
in your history to just pause for a
second you're gonna get that doctor you
for sure are you're going to run the
organization but give yourself a time to
get the professional experience and
wisdom that you're going to need to do
that job i want to thank george campbell
campbell george kim so close what
happened man a b for available
[Music]
did you know you can listen to the
ramsay show on your smart speaker just
tell alexa google assistant or siri to
play the ramsay show podcast
check out all ramsay network shows on
your smart speaker today
[Music]